Tom here's a question for you some of
the people on the other side are talking
about the mistakes DeSantis made with
Disney there's data where we can look at
to see if it's favoring him or if it's
hurting Disney was this a good thing for
the scientists to go after Disney at a
time like this or is this something that
Bob Iger is doing because he needs it
like you were talking about off podcast
there's a little bit of everything going
on there so if people were listening to
this just listen objectively to win
DeSantis on Twitter spaces said it's not
fair that Disney has their own way and
doesn't pay taxes while Sea World
Universal and the others are paying
taxes as all the wonderful tourists come
to Florida to enjoy themselves and go to
these theme parks he made that point and
remember you know Universal that's owned
by another media giant so the other
media Giants saying damn straight I'm
paying my taxes ABC you know and uh
Disney or not and so there is an angle
there that was very truthful that say
hey I'm trying to even the playing field
up and they're trying to make it sound
like oh it's because of woke things
however Rob if you can go find a Disney
stock chart and just go back six months
just click on Disney stock chart six
months Bob Iger rolled into town right
after Thanksgiving remember that it was
right after Thanksgiving our hero is
back it's like a Disney movie you know
here he is and he immediately started
laying off people he announced that they
were changing some things that were
going on remember they raised parking
rates and stuff and he was trying to
change some of the pricing at the um at
the theme parks but Bob Iger has his
hands full and I believe this
controversy is helping Bob Iger move the
dialogue that's on his desk which is
fixed Disney so take a look here go back
six months right there you had a little
pop-up where you had this ramp that ran
up to February that's called the we're
glad our hero is back and the Disney
goes from 85 to 110. but now look since
that point on Feb February 2nd Pat look
at that it's a trend line down it's gone
up down up down but it's heading down
it's because Bob Iger has not been able
to right away from 110 to 85. that's
that's not good yeah
if we can I I don't want to cut you off
if you go to Max
Disney's the first stock I've ever owned
in my life my grandmother bought me
stock when I was a kid and I've had it
forever if you go back to I think this
is pre-covered I want to say go back to
the high point I think it hit 180 at one
point October of 2020 so even in during
covet it was at 181 right maybe you
could tell the full breadth of the story
of what actually happened since covet
where because his woke agenda with with
Bob Iger and everything that's happening
with the Santas is a six-month story
your story but it's really a two three
year story of what's happening with
Disney correct but it's our hero coming
back remember jpeck was trying to stand
behind the scenes the former CEO he was
behind the scenes he was supporting a
woke agenda but he was not at war with
DeSantis there had been some words like
hey buddy you know we may need to talk
about your tax saying the war really
started between Iger and DeSantis and
DeSantis is just saying hey Disney you
need to be just like Universal just like
Sea World just like animal kingdom all
the stuff you need to pay your taxes and
you had a benefit an economic benefit
called economic development that all
cities do to attract business and
DeSantis is like I think 50 years of
Economic Development benefits is enough
and I'm going to take it back and Iger
is out there trying to address
profitability but now he's talking about
this because it's the blame game he's
got something to believe he's got
something to blame it's not my fault he
did it it's Ron Ron did it they did it
if if it wasn't for Ron this would have
never happened to us that's what Iger
saying that's that's kind of what Tom is
saying great point which Disneyland was
closed and which was open making Disney
money Florida
so chapek and Iger and the Disney
shareholders owe a little bit of a thank
you because there is millions of dollars
of ebitda that was created because
Disney was open and California was
closed is brilliant we all know Iger is
a genius we all know Iger is on the list
of top 10 top five Executives I'd say
top 10 Executives in the last no he's
probably top five top five Executives in
the last 40 years who do you put ahead
of them I only think about a couple
names and I'm talking I'm not talking
Founders because he's not a Founder I'm
talking executive so you can't put a
jobs or you know or some of these guys
exactly you got to put the Welch's of
40. you got a few names but I don't even
know if I put Welch ahead of him I think
Welch was for this guy to buy and
negotiate all the deals and get like
guys like jobs to
agreed to sell to what like no that's
not normal to do that
I think Bob Iger has to have a meeting
with his wife with his family with his
kids with his close friends with the
people he respects the most who will
give him sincere feedback if he hasn't
already had this meeting and guess what
Bob get in the ring
make a decision to get in the ring yes
get in the ring because oh it's too late
no it's not about this one here in the
next one here but start planning you
going into the ring you know it it
sounds like a guy that's itching to
fight these heavyweights but he's doing
it from the outside and he's a little
scared if you've read his book
he talks about it that he was sitting
with Murdoch I believe who was he
sitting with Murdoch or one of those
guys Roger Ailes yeah and he was talking
about the fact that he has asked well
are you going to run for president he's
like I told him no but I was thinking
about running for president why don't
you just make a decision and run and
tell the world about it look by the way
he wrote a book look how many views it's
got look how many reasons got wow 21 22
000 reviews right there I mean that's a
three-year-old book four-year-old book
that's doing that well so it's going to
be interesting to see what happens so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign